[Music]
a day-long ceasefire in Sudan is in
doubt after gunfire Was Heard shortly
after the truce was set to begin at
least 185 people have been killed in a
violent power struggle between the Army
and Sudan's largest paramilitary Force
the rapid support forces both sides are
blaming each other for violating the
truce once again putting civilians in
the crossfire altazira's Hippa Morgan is
in Khartoum
more explosions in Sudan's capital
hartum in the first minutes of what was
supposed to be a ceasefire but did not
take effect as Sudan's Army and most
powerful paramilitary fights each other
for the fourth day fighting continued at
hartum airport leaving a trail of
Destruction satellite pictures show
widespread damage after days of heavy
fighting flights have been suspended
preventing International mediators from
arriving 330 kilometers north of hartum
merui air base is still being contested
by rival military forces Sudan's Army
claimed on Tuesday that it has control
of the facility Army Chief General Abdel
fattah al-burhan and his Deputy Muhammad
hamdan who leads the paramilitary rapid
support forces had been in charge of the
country since 2019 but they disagree on
how to restore civilian rule it's
unclear who now has the upper hand with
fighting around the general command
military headquarters the rapid support
forces really least footage purporting
to show its troops gaining ground with
its soldiers at the security services
building but after the Army took back
control of State TV on Monday it's
called on the rsf to turn themselves in
it is not in the interest of our
homeland to have its own countrymen
carrying arms against one another
therefore we call on them not to be part
of this conspiracy to lay down arms and
turn themselves in and then let's see if
they will consider joining the ranks of
Sudan's Armed Forces
Khartoum and other cities are now
battlefields with tanks rolling through
the streets and dead bodies strewn
across Pavements medical staff are
warning they can't reach the injured
because hospitals are under attack
there's not enough medicine food or
water with power Cuts generators are
operating at critical levels
people in hartum had hoped the ceasefire
would hold many have reported missing
relatives and want to find them but
scanned because of the continuous
fighting and others say they've not been
able to bury their dead
but some are venturing out to find
supplies
we have bought six packs of noodles two
pack can feed three people for one meal
there is also salt and cake the cake
will expire tomorrow so we can have it
for dinner tonight there's a global push
to find diplomatic resolve the U.S is
urging warring parties to end
hostilities I made calls to generals
burhan and hamedi
urging them to agree to a 24-hour
ceasefire to allow Sudanese to safely
reunite with their families and to
obtain desperately needed relief
supplies for now it's unclear if the two
generals are willing to Heed These
requests as their Capital City continues
its descent into a war zone Heber Morgan
Al Jazeera Khartoum
some desperate people in cartoon have
risked going out to get essential
supplies they say they have no food or
water and the Panic is setting in
common
the situation is very hard that's not a
secret to anyone it was sudden there's
no electricity no water it is the fourth
day in a row without water we don't know
what will happen in the coming days but
I hope for the best
great struggle no water no
no four days the children are terrified
Sudan's Health Ministry says the
violence has forced at least 16
hospitals to shut down it says that
number is likely to rise and is urging
the warring sides to refrain from
attacking Health Facilities some clinics
have been bombed While others have
closed due to a lack of supplies Sudan's
doctors committee says they're
struggling to treat the injured
or the ongoing fighting and supply
shortages of forced hospitals in
Khartoum to close all patients except
those in the Intensive Care Unit have
been evacuated from the capital's
Children's Hospital
with the escalation of violence and
security tensions the doctors had to
evacuate all the cases except the cases
inside the Intensive Care units there is
a shortage in staff medicine and oxygen
the hospital is witnessing a shortage in
many things even the doctors we have
left
shortly after the ceasefire was supposed
to come into Force the UN under
Secretary General for humanitarian
Affairs Martin Griffiths tweeted the
targeting of humanitarian workers and
Facilities continues in Sudan we're
receiving reports of attacks and sexual
violence against Aid workers this is
unacceptable and must stop
I've had Omar is the communications
coordinator at the Norwegian Refugee
Council he's concerned about reports of
attacks on Aid workers and says that
it's crucial for humanitarian access to
be restored to help refugees
we need this humanitarian access to
these people because these people they
depend on us there are a lot of
emergencies happening and NRC is
supporting a lot of emergencies in these
camps and now it has been uh since April
15 now we stopped from working we
stopped from responding to our refugees
uh for example here in gadarif alone we
have about 41
000 and 500 assuming refugees that we
are serving
so we need an urgent ceasefire and if we
have a ceasefire of course we should we
will always we will immediately start
our work we'll go continue our work in
the camps and to help the refugees
that we are helping and the this place
that we are helping uh but ceasefire we
we learned that there are some ceasefire
for example yesterday but it was not uh
fully ceasefire and today also we heard
about ceasefire but it didn't happen uh
it happened what happened actually is
opposite uh we had now a lot of uh a big
Clash a big conflict in cartoon NOS we
are so worried about that since we hear
that there are three uh un staff that
got attacked in Darfur uh this also
might happen to us we are all
humanitarian workers and this really is
it's a real concern for us